Okay, let's get into a audience questions
for the week.
Three questions every week
today.
Today's from Brian.
Brian says, Hey David, what evidence leads
you to believe people are fundamentally or
generally good like you and Joe Rogan both
said on the Joe Rogan show?
Well, so this is a very old philosophical
question, a question that exists even beyond
philosophy.
Are we inherently good or bad?
Uh, what about our greedy instincts?
What about our selfless instincts?
What about evolutionary advantages that one
or the other types of behavior conveys?
I don't know that I have anything particularly
new to add to it.
I'll, I'll just give you my take on it.
I believe people are generally what I would
call good, despite admittedly selfish and
greedy instincts that many of us have.
There's a few actual data points if you want
to look at it.
There are some pretty good studies from Harvard
and Yale about what are called first instincts
in a variety of different tests.
And people's instincts are overall tend to
be towards cooperation, uh, even if selfishness
is in the background as a motive sometimes
for that cooperation.
And that brings us to what I think are some
of the more compelling, um, uh, sort of data
points on this, which are evolutionary advantages.
Humans that better cooperate historically
have done best.
So in a sense, there has been a natural selection
towards cooperation and people that are, um,
uh, sort of open to acting in a way that benefits
their group even if underlying that are selfish
or self centered interests.
And I think one of the really interesting
things about this is, uh, a lot of the history
on the evolutionary role of religion.
And although I am not religious myself and
I believe that modern religion is rife with
problematic ideas, dogmatic, blindly dogmatic
thinking, uh, defenses of violence justified
by sacred tax.
I mean, all the people who watched the show
know my position on this.
I actually do believe that there are many
points in history where religious belief conferred
and evolutionary advantage where if you were
not in the in religious group, it was less
likely that there would be sort of cooperative
relationships with the people you were living
with, whether it's in a village or or wherever
else.
Um, and that, uh, those people tended to not
do as well.
So yes, selfish instincts exist, but over
time, nature in a sense has selected for cooperative
tendencies.
Even if those tendencies are rooted in some
longterm plan that is selfish.
In other words, well, I will act in a way
that is cooperative because I believe that
that will actually better serve me personally
in the long run.
While you're still cooperating.
In that sense, there are also studies on babies
which have found that at really early points
where we can even get a sense of what is going
on in the baby's mind.
Babies have an instinct for fairness over
unfairness.
As soon as they can recognize it and they
seem to prefer good over evil.
They don't like unfairness in puppet shows
at very early ages.
They tend to away from violence at very early
ages and in the end, statistically, most people
are not violent people who are committing
acts of violence in the real world.
Most people are not criminals as defined by
society.
Most people lie mostly only in the sense of
white lies.
People do not like and react positively to
new use of criminality or violence or war
or terrorism or conflict, and certainly they're
not participating in it themselves.
So of course reality is complex.
Evil exists to the extent that that's what
we want to call it.
Radicalization exists, but I believe people,
most people are fundamentally and generally
good.
It's been not only informed by my personal
experience, but also by all of the different
data points that I've mentioned here.
Uh, all of which are widely available for
you to find disagree with me, let me know.
Are, are people fundamentally not good?
Are People fundamentally bad or evil or violent
or whatever?
Uh, I'd love to hear from you about this next
question today.